- Hello, I'm Dolph
Ziggler and welcome to
At Midnight Master Class.
I will be making a man
bun of my messy dreads.
The secret to the
perfect man bun,
I as first and foremost
being the perfect man,
so if you're not me,
feel free to practice
on Barbie dolls or Ken dolls
or anything that you
can get your hands on,
some shrubbery.
A man bun says about
your personality
that you don't care what
anyone thinks, in the 80s.
So to make a bun, first
of all, make sure you have
long, horse's mane like
locks and then reach
into your skinny jeans,
grab a fancy rubber band
that you can
probably get at H&M,
pull tight, and if
you're on the West Coast,
feel free to give yourself
that homemade facelift
by pulling tighter.
I'm 36, but I can play
29 because of this.
Pull it straight, wrap
around each finger twice,
wrap it around once.
For those of you cardio guys
and for the body guys like me,
two I can get it around.
Make sure your skinny tie
is just a little askew.
You're ready to douche it up.
That has been At
Midnight Master Class
and I am Dalph Ziggler.
Good evening.